hello everybody and welcome to a
brand-new let's play of the things in
the night this is obviously an amnesia
custom story if you couldn't tell by now
video but anyway this is a mod custom
story that is unusually highly reviewed
like ten out of ten nine point nine very
very highly so I am interested I was
okay I said I was gonna stay away from
and these forbid but I came across and I
was so curious about it that I had to
play it so here we go it's by a guy
named John owed it all began on one
night full of rain and thunders someone
knocked on your door you decide to get
up to check what's happening and end up
noticing there's a letter in a puddle of
water next to your entrance door PS to
get a better experience play this mod at
night when it's dark with your
headphones on in the volume up good
advice
good advice so let's get to it
let's see what this is all about
ah oh that wasn't a knock oh hello
hey I'm actually in a bed hmm well short
how Scratchy
what the hell ooh fancy
interesting nice Yousef nice use of
lighting
well and I lack the music I had I got a
note what's that noise coming from down
that's coming from downstairs before
checking it I need to get my lantern
that's in the next room okey-dokey
I didn't think that but of course this
is you I like this something it it kind
of feels interesting
very very nice
okay yeah
nice way of portraying that it's raining
outside - hey Marie yeah change on me
actually in the laughs it's my few mods
I've played that hasn't changed much
right
haha there is kick kick and I don't have
full of oil but that's okay
anything behind here and it's my house
I'll knock over everything if I want to
get out of here that's right that's what
I don't
Wow now you ventured down who's there
someone's rummaging through my goodies
and no one touches my goodies hello
what's all this Wow I have a nice house
load of measures that's so cute
they're adorable Oh Oh foot prints ah
are they going that way or that way oh
hello dear brother I don't know if this
letter will make it to you I send it
with one of my loyal servants but I
think he's being followed and I hope he
doesn't lead you to what I call the
essence of evil but I've got no other
choice
you know dad has always been in the
shadows of evil science and now he has
found something with great power that I
can't even begin to understand I only
got the general idea by reading his
notes and it seems it has something to
do with living forever and raising the
dead for his bidding but all this comes
with a price there's no time for that
right now you need to come home to chupa
as fast a [ __ ]
the rest of the letter is too wet for me
to read she said I must leave tonight
there's no time to waste
take me about three days to get there
but first I need to go back upstairs and
get the front door key next to my bed
and I should get some mesh from the
icebox in the kitchen oh there's a bad
idea
this is a bad idea Oh fire thinks just
why as a stove still on who left the
stove on okay
oh this bad idea
oh this is the icebox quote-unquote
interesting Wow I really like it when
people take interesting steps to make
sure that things look good
Oh someone was just jacking my WAN and
everybody that sounds weird yeah I
really like the way this guy is
portraying things in unique and
interesting ways that's what I like and
maybe and I I'm hoping that the reviews
on the site weren't just fluff reviews
they were actually legitimate stuff why
didn't I pick up this key before I need
to get stupid to fight and find my
mother and brother who will take me
three days to get there aren't I worried
about the thing that was in my house
wouldn't I just be a squeeze worried
about that there were obvious footprints
someone just wanted to get my wine and
get out there that makes sense
Wow cool once again very cool creepy
welcome to chupa I don't think that says
that man this this this town lags my
computer Ben I need to look for my
brother I hope he's all right
wow this is this definitely lagging like
a fever hello is someone there
right okay first I'll start off by not
looking at him and I'll check these
houses nope I will not taboo blah yeah
whenever I point my camera down that
down that way it's because there's so
much stuff because you can see in the
distance is just huge huge amounts of
stuff and probably the engine isn't used
to processing stuff like that I don't
knock it it's so good oh that doesn't
look good
the captain hmm it looks like some of
the houses have their lights off I
should check those ones first after I
find the ruins some years ago I used to
live here there are some old ruins of
the far top left of this town's woods
all I have to do to get there is to stay
on the left side of this sidewalk until
I see a sign good enough I need to check
the houses with the lights off
anybody home I'm not some big scary
monster that also murdered everyone
loose man girl
that's weird yeah what oh well I know
thank you
good kind sir from the grave
shut up moves man
okay here some light that's not door
never mind
all right lights on lights on lights on
that lights off ooh this don't look good
ah that must be a key this town is
rather large I'll be able to find a key
whatever ah oh hi there hey buddy how
are you doing I'm gonna go over here now
ah come on what this holy crap bolla
that is a cool looking place this guy
built some really interesting stuff
Donald Donald is his name
I can't go that way like I applaud
efforts like this and one of the reasons
that I'm so excited for a machine for
pigs is because dried up well danger
stay out no I don't think so okay I need
to look around town a bit more five
whatever you say
yeah one of the reasons I'm so excited
for machine for pigs is the fact that it
will allow for greater variety of
environments and tooling to make more
interesting custom stories because I'm
almost positive that the developers know
that the success of their own of their
own game is due in large part to their
ability to make custom stories and mods
so easily modding is a huge thing in the
PC gaming community if your game can mod
and it's good in the first place and you
have the right tools there you will get
people more interested in your game and
it will drive your business that's
what's important oh boy I I have
pictures of you this guy must be a
celebrity or something
ask for the doctor I think the doctor is
dead footprints double footprints
someone playing hopscotch all the way
down here or leapfrog lab door Noi
nah ah anything here no how about here
new chair new drawer hmm
ah their shoes give give give give you
perfect oh oh oh no
okay I'm I'm okay I'm okay
hmm strange footprints gotta use stuff
and I'm burning through oil I'm not
doing uh oh no oh sorry about that
yeah sorry buddy didn't mean to bug you
I'll just go in here for a second
was that one of them fakie fakie
monsters I like a fakie pinkie monster
I don't have any oh I do what did I get
tinderboxes how's a fakie fakie yeah
didn't think so
oh I was closing in anyway didn't you
slamming oh oh oh oh god it smells so
bad in here could have done this to the
Vizier's Cather's cuz I said
like I don't know how he's doing it for
some reason well as I'm playing it feels
like the game is different barn key ah
the barn ever
yeah the way oh oh
whoa I've never actually well I've never
actually taken a look up close at one of
these guys I've seen the dead ones
before but I've never seen this one oh
look at this guy ha oh oh oh my how are
you doing buddy hey good to see I
it's not even fluffs of hair good he'll
uh pay me like one of your french girls
ah okay bye-bye now
okay man all right that's that's creepy
another one right you're gonna I came
oh here we are all right that's grody
this is and I did nothing
man
ah here we are sanity potion ah empty
jar and I'm guessing some acid right
here that I could take oh no really
for once I'm not getting the acid let's
see what the note said it looks like I
can use this to heat up a jar with
something in it hmm interesting good gah
I know I know I know uh I guess I better
I mean this is the first time I'm going
through a custom story and I'm taking it
slow like really looking at everything
and that's cool it feels more like
immersive okay so anyway I got a jar and
I can heat it up here but I don't have
anything to heat it up heat up because I
don't have anything in it fill up the
jar here no okay I'm guessing I'm gonna
go to the barn now cuz I got the barn
doors
okay something's gonna pop out
No ah man I'm ex I'm actually out of
time so thank you all so much for
watching hope you're enjoying this
custom story I know I am this is really
great I can see why it's so highly
reviewed so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye